[Música]
o anos mais essa é bom voltar a casa e
sem perder mais tempo
vou começar a contar a minha história
que as 5º xii no bairro mais difícil
inês live nos envolvemos numa luta temos
uma regra apenas uma regra não pensava
como queríamos contar vamos votar o
quanto queremos só entrava uma coisa
como um levantava essa era para mim o
importante é um discurso muito bonito
como chover mercado de trabalho e é
inspirado até num filme chamado gente no
destino
organizado pelo método da irmã onde
exatamente isso conta uma história
bonita para cativar a platéia e para
ganhar a confiança da platéia mas dá nos
uma lição que é nem todos têm histórias
tristes no início e não nem todos temos
fazer aqui o discurso da treta que somos
uns coitadinhos
isso explica porque eu sinceramente
sinto um privilegiado e vou explicar por
que vocês também são os privilegiados e
porque é que com honra já a idéia da
escada ou uma corrida não começamos
todos no mesmo sítio a pessoas que
começam bem abaixo do nosso e essas
pessoas também devemos respeitá lo
por isso eu ponho os bancos provar que
vocês também são privilegiados um
exercício de um filósofo americano
século 21 conhecido john roll e peço que
exponham debaixo de um véu de ignorância
imaginem que está numa posição de
completo imparcialidade
vocês não sabem em qual estudam em país
vivem em família estão condições é em
geral e agora pensa em sociedade é que
vocês criam sem saber o que é que vocês
têm
o aumento seria uma sociedade melhor do
poço tem agora condições melhores do que
agora
mas não seria assim tão diferente e se
nós tivemos fizemos uma tabela e 101 7
milhões de pessoas neste mundo você
olhar tanto no topo desta tabela em
termos de condições de vida por isso
pergunto se provará
o que você chama os pronunciados só
assim eles brincavam também pela nigéria
probabilidade de virem a ter uma vida
melhor que no momento justo seria que a
probabilidade de se criar 10 por trocar
esta vida toda possa está em evento em
uma probabilidade 1 vaga para um sítio
bem pior do que vocês têm agora se
calhar estarem na síria numa guerra a
tentar fugir dela
se calhar faria e nem de com crianças a
trabalhar ou em áfrica ou uma doença
terminal é de 160
vamos voltar e isso mas fiquem conhece
daí nem todos começamos no mesmo sítio e
vocês começaram mais acima do que outras
pessoas como eu também como está
outro exemplo que um filme da neci
filmar um conjunto de dois genes que são
os agentes do time que tentam controlar
o destino das pessoas o destino das
pessoas já está traçado e nos limitam se
enquadrá las porque elas sigam esse
mesmo destino
olha em primeiro lugar como você achava
isso é verdade
na vida real não acontece nós não temos
pessoas num gabinete a orientarem nossa
vida
por isso estamos a pagar 13 das
essenciais primário quando solano estima
há uma coisa que é certa como já foi
aqui falar quero nem nada não é algo
isolado vão seguir outras pessoas só
porque sim não é necessariamente uma boa
ideia porque não quer dizer que elas
estejam no caminho certo
a segunda coisa é que somos nós
controlamos o nosso time
se calhar num todo e já vamos falar
nisso mais à frente mas a grande parte
somos nós pois o trio e parece
contraditória é que às vezes não somos
nós controlamos o nosso time e isso não
é necessariamente mau
e vou explicar porque eu entrei pro
colégio em 2007 era muito mais pequeno
do que sou agora
e sou x é no início chorava chorava
o primeiro período que passei o prêmio
toda chorar e crescido coelho
ele só meu pai de família humilde eu
quero ser do colégio não estou aqui e um
pai disse-me o seguinte não tem ainda
condições necessárias para tomar uma
decisão ainda não viver sustentou o
colégio poder tomar uma decisão e um
país um pensa vai ficar no prejuízo até
o final do primeiro ano
vamos fazer a mesma pergunta que se ache
no prédio na altura o time do colégio
o que é facto é que voltei a jogar no
último dia do 1º ano mas chorei porque
no clipe a casa cria ficar com os
camaradas no curso cria ficar congelados
que me ajudaram a estar no colégio e
fica lá e tive a oportunidade de voltar
a jogar com muito orgulho
anos mais tarde quando tiver a
possibilidade de fazer o último filme na
avenida da liberdade
se eu tivesse a possibilidade de tomar a
decisão hoje não estaria aqui e não
teria estado oito anos magníficos no
colégio
ainda bem que nem todas as decisões
sobre o nosso mando pois o trânsito está
um é que como falei ao caso que há
pessoas a viver situações bem piores que
a nossa alguma coisa temos ter bem
presente desdramatizar alguns problemas
que nós temos
às vezes vivendo num ambiente fechado
pensamos que alguns dos nossos problemas
são grandes coisas mas tendo são
cápsulas a viver problemas a sério é
veículo considerarmos um verdadeiro
dilema algumas coisas que consideramos
mas isso não invalida que tínhamos que
tomar decisões e temos que lutar por
coisas que acreditamos
mas foi isso e aproveitando as palavras
que foram ditas por antigos comandante
do batalhão que já foram vai implicar
uma ideia já que liga foi do almirante
nelson motta são francisco assis não
sabe ao certo mas a idéia é um simples e
os alunos em três palavras de coragem
paciência e sabedoria
vocês tomarem uma decisão tem que ter em
conta essas três coisas precisam ter
coragem para saber para quando tem que
mudar uma coisa teria coragem pra mudar
preciso paciência para compreender que
vocês não podem mudar tudo e precisam de
saber do dia e distinguir e será entre
essas duas situações estas três letras
coragem e paciência e sabedoria
estiveram basta minha graduação do
comandante do batalhão durante o ano
inteiro está neste momento também
embaixo da graduação do vosso comando do
batalhão para quando tomar decisões
lembramo-nos dessas três palavras-chave
depois outra coisa pensar em si é
importante compreender é que é
primordial manson lembrar desta equação
custo em uma carta de motivação para
antes da prova única
nós somos o que agora nós somos é
basicamente o que já fizemos a nossa
bagagem nossas histórias morris de
vivências e aquilo creche e uma coisa
importante nessa bagagem que nós temos é
que temos que fazer alguma coisa temos
territórios por contar um homem sem
histórias pra contar
é um homem seja isso é como ar serviço e
é um homem vazio
por isso amizades que vocês têm que
indicar a viagem que tem que fazer
especialmente com amigos mesmo também
sozinho ea vivência tem que ser coisas
horríveis podem acontecer mas será uma
história que está um exemplo que
infelizmente uma viagem por um roubo em
cuba eu costumo dizer que nós vamos
deixar uma parte nós em que lugar do
mundo eu fiz questão de deixar o meu
pênis mas é uma história que possam
contar
apesar de a perceber que nem conversa
com o antigo álbum também que tem uma
história melhor que eu porque eu sou o
pênis em timor uma situação mais
complicada mas é sempre aquela temos foi
na velocidade uma maneira de contar
histórias e depois quando falamos de das
pichações e do nosso futuro há uma coisa
é certa quando pensamos para frente não
podemos prescindir de sete shows nós
temos nesta casa
infelizmente nós temos uma bússola que
permitisse que nos jogos completamente
desorientado quando vamos lá por fora e
integridade de caráter é uma coisa que
nós não podemos perder
por isso vocês têm isso escrito nos
vossos homens têm muitas paredes em
espalhadas pelo colégio
não é difícil de cumprir e fará com que
não se percam nesta vindo aqui que às
vezes pode voar por caminhos errados
depois a figuras podemos ter como
inspiração tem que inúmeros exemplos me
acho que os outros mas também podem
implicar em termos mais fotos mais
próximo de graduados que neste caso
fizeram com que voz e ficassem no
colégio e que está em jogo aqui hoje e
que tenham certas condições que não
tinham outra maneira mas uma figura
também que pra nós todos versão exemplo
nosso marshall fundador
e fizemos familiar que gosto muito do de
usar é uma história do de inspiração
nesse caso é o novo e infelizmente esta
semana teve um avc mas é uma história de
vida que que eu guardo como fonte de
inspiração isto porque o novo começou a
trabalhar aos 16 anos a vender leite
eu tenho 20 ainda não tenho um trabalho
sério e uma volta depois de defender
light passado muito tempo ter fazer o
serviço militar obrigatório
quando voltou e vendas fracas todas se
faltar a começar te faltará vendê lo mas
tanto o trabalho estão sozinhas começou
a expandir o seu negócio e consegui um
das porradas da roupa e não parecia
vender roupa por todo o país
o novo conseguiu juntar alguma solução
com o aumento esse tenha sido o trabalho
eu e acima tudo ao meu lado foi um homem
que usava boné tudo que juntou ainda há
pouco tempo agora por razões isso não
tanto mas houve a partir pedra no jardim
de uma coisa que não precisava de fazer
porque tinha nem a propagar as pessoas
faziam scliar poderia ser um trabalho
inútil mas sim é esta chama cá dentro
que continuar a fazer alguma coisa e
depois uma coisa que para nós é bastante
importante e que é uma certeza que às
vezes nos esquecemos nesta vida que é
exatamente o oposto da vida é morta nós
vamos todos morrer e expressa uma frase
pouco limpa ou em tom jocoso ea música
sobre isso mas é uma realidade temos que
encarar não é o nosso maior medo pois o
houve um estudo que diz que seu maior
medo do ser humano é falar em público
mas sou sincero eu fiz aqui e são
provavelmente hora soltar mais longe do
segundo medo mas prefiro falar em
público que morrer e acreditem que que a
morte se calhar é uma coisa que não
desejamos mas a maneira daquela é algo
inevitável tudo bem é ao pode ser minado
várias maneiras e constante também
everest como os gato fedorento que
parece brincadeira mas a letra faz
sentido mas uma das missões que também
aprendi mês grima e que só por pia muito
bem isto é que é pior maneira e que já
fez em mim mas sabe muito bem da maneira
mais estúpidas poderia deixar passar o
tempo
por isso os desafios a não deixarem
passar o tempo não andarem distraídos na
vida e fazer alguma coisa e não
esperarem preparem uma escada pra
começar a deixar um lugar porque uma
coisa é certa este caminho você estou
agora a começar vai acabar num grande
abismo é uma escalada que vai acabar no
vídeo no final vamos todos morrer é uma
realidade temos que esperar mas tenham
pelo menos uma oportunidade de adquirir
neste abismo
antes do show será do primeiro olhar
paulo gato que deixaram e poder
desfrutar da vista
obrigado a todos se apresentar aqui
[Aplausos]
[Música]